[Music]
you know I didn't realize is that you
began your career as a dancer you just
like JLo I color JLo you may know her as
Jennifer Lopez you you are on in living
color you are Fly Girl it was kind of
late 80s Early 90s moves in aviary do
you have those moves you have those
moves cuz I have watching for years and
I know you have like a dance background
or something have you I go no I'm just
had too much sugar
I really have to know it's funny we had
Dick Van Dyke here the other day and he
was talking about I was like you've done
all this great dancing over the years
and all these you know and you moved so
well and he said he never had a dance
lesson he never did any dancing all to
who's in his thirties I just jump around
a lot and people like you clearly had
training for a tall man you're very
coordinated and you know I mean I think
here's the thing I I like it don't get
me wrong I find it very sexy but I think
that you can smooth out some of your
moves because it looks like you're being
electrocuted from the waist kind of like
you mean the beginning you started doing
this like no you don't do that you
didn't do that that was great what you
were doing though do you have I do it
yeah I'm Brad got a jerky motion
movement yeah and I like anyone tuning
in right now thinks the set is broken
they're calling the cable company right
now and they're like wondering what's
wrong with my television set smooth it
out it's smooth you just gotta be really
okay you do it
do whatever yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm just gonna do the electric I like
watching you more but you know part of
it is just looking cool yeah like you
were talking to the wrong guy